[Musique]
thomas habituellement le 1er mai est un
jour de mobilisation pour des milliers
de personnes
cette place emblématique où vous situez
accueille normalement les manifestations
parisiennes chaque année mais elle est
vide ou presque les pas de manifestation
pas de défilé autorisé cette année pour
cette journée internationale des
travailleurs alors il ya quand même eu
quelques manifestants entre cinq et dix
personnes qui ont tenté de se rassembler
sur cette place de la république ils ont
arboré une banderole ils ont très vite
été interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
qui vous le voyez sont déployées en
nombre il ya eu un important dispositif
policier qui a été dépêché sur cette
place de la république avec des renforts
désormais qu'ils sont arrivés notamment
la brigade motorisée qui est arrivé ici
il n'ya pas il n'y a plus aucun
manifestant que les choses soient bien
claires la place de la république est
désormais vide mais il ya donc eu des
interpellations de l'interpellation plus
tôt aux muscles et pour certaines
d'entre elles et il est évidemment
interdit de se rassembler alors ces
manifestants portaient des masques et
des visières de sécurité mais ce n'est
évidemment malgré tout interdit de se
rassembler comme l'a précisé d'ailleurs
le président de la république dans un
message qu'il a adressé ce matin sur
twitter on écoute mes chers compatriotes
ce 1er mai 2020 ne ressemble à aucun
autre
aujourd'hui pas de rassemblement dans
nos villes pour fêter comme nous
faisions depuis tant d'années
la journée internationale des
travailleurs et je veux avoir une pensée
en ce jour pour les organisations
syndicales qui ne peuvent tenir les
traditionnels défilés avoir une pensée
pour les travailleuses et les
travailleurs de notre pays
alors avec toutes ces mesures de
restrictions de déplacements et de
confinement pour ceux qui veulent
néanmoins manifesté il faut se
réinventer et c'est sur internet et sur
les réseaux sociaux que se déroule
maintenant des manifestations numérique
comme nous l'expliquent bérenger cernon
il est membre du syndicat cgt cheminots
c'est le but c'est d'occuper l'espace
entre guillemets à médiatique qui nous a
offert un verre la tribune que sont les
réseaux sociaux voilà en utilisant le
hashtag plus jamais ça en utilisant bien
évidemment des photos des vidéos en les
diffusant au maximum sur les réseaux
sociaux
et puis voilà l'affiché aux yeux de tous
et tous pour montrer que même dans ces
moments difficiles on n'est pas seuls on
est soudé et puis surtout de donner
rendez vous voilà dès qu'on aura la
possibilité de sortir parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit le patronat n'a
pas perdu ses vieux précède du 19e
siècle où c'est quand je perds tu
rembourses et puis quand je gagne et
battu père aussi donc voilà le combat le
combat continue malgré confinement alors
si beaucoup prennent leur mal en
patience et attendre la levée du
confinement pour organiser à nouveau des
manifestations et des rassemblements il
y a toutefois quelques appels aux
manifestations aujourd'hui en cette
journée du 1er mai c'est donc le cas sur
cette place de la république où je vous
le répète entre cinq et dix personnes se
sont rassemblées il ya d'autres appels
qui circulent actuellement sur les
réseaux sociaux mais comme vous l'avez
compris les forces de l'ordre veillent
au grain et sont présentes en nombre
pour bien empêcher ces rassemblements
aujourd'hui
merci thomas bonnet pour toutes ces
précisions depuis la place de la
république à paris et dans mon cas